another huge twist in the elon musk
twitter saga the world's richest man is
putting his 44 billion dollar twitter
takeover temporarily on hold but then
insisting he's still committed to
completing the acquisition quote twitter
deal temporarily on hold pending details
supporting calculation that spam fake
accounts so do represent less than five
percent of users musk needs to act fast
biden's new disinformations are already
think she's qualified to start editing
your tweets
verified people can
um
essentially start to edit twitter
the same sort of way that wikipedia is
so they can add context to certain
tweets
and speaking of disinformation the white
house sure knows how to traffic in it
they tweeted out a bogus claim that
there was no vaccine available when
biden took office which is a flat out
lie
hit it jesse
well first of all that woman is a snob
jankowitz but there's nothing worse than
being a saab it's a snob that works in
government that combination is really
deadly i don't know what musk is trying
to do you can't monetize a bot you can't
make money off a bot so if they're
boosting the bot count then he's paying
over price for the platform so he needs
to figure it out or he's trying to cut
loose from the deal because the market's
tanking especially tech rates are going
up maybe he can't get the financing he
thought i don't know what he's trying to
do but i like what he's trying to do
here you're b you're able to get paid
for certain tweets and i love that idea
if you have a tweet that goes viral like
this tweet went viral quarter million
people liked it there's a funny tweet
she says i've started reading before bed
instead of scrolling twitter and not
only am i sleeping really well but i
also think i'm better than everyone
so that got a quarter million likes
and that's pretty funny so she should be
able to get paid for that yeah
i agree oh yeah you don't think that's
funny yeah you just told me you read
before bed last night and you think
you're better than everybody i know
250 000
pants i'm fine
[Laughter]
big difference she knows all right tyrus
let's let's get back look elon musk's
speculation that he wants to get out of
the deal but there's also speculation
that he's just trying to get the price
down what do you think i don't think
it's either those things i think he's
exposing more of their uh what's the
shenanigans there we go or bs
so they're saying it's less than five
percent and i too think it's a lot
bigger number than that i think a lot of
the things that we see on twitter are
pushed by fake accounts bots and fake
algorithms so he's going to expose and
people will start seeing that maybe that
number is like 20 percent which makes a
huge difference when you look at how
information has been pushed forward it
only furthers his cause to why he needs
to buy it and it's because let's face it
the woke are a lot of things but the
woke ain't going broke every one of
those stockholders they want they want
those chips yeah but he's going to
before you go the people are going to
see your real face that's what i think
this is about emily don't you think that
uh more than anything elon musk is the
guy who knows how to negotiate 100 right
he's been called an erratic visionary
and manic he could be a lot of things
but i think he knows what he's doing to
the tune of his 43 billion dollars and i
think you know to root this down the
whole purpose is his duty to the
shareholders and to the value right so
if you learn after you've proffered 43
billion that it's actually worth 20
because 20 of those accounts are fake
then why should he fork over all of
those billions right so i think that the
rumors about him wanting to back out are
inaccurate i think he wants to get the
value for his dollar because after he
takes this private then he's going to
want to drive it up because for him
that's where the profit is and i think
that the added bonus is the dedication
to that that public square of free
speech that we are all on board with but
bottom line it's about that bottom
dollar
okay
so
[Laughter]
the white house the verified account
tweets today
that covid vaccine wasn't available
until joe biden came in now let me ask
you a question
leslie
why is it still up
why didn't they why didn't they content
moderate that oh it's a lie oh please
people people lie about i'm not even an
important person people lie about like
me every single day there are lies out
there coming from everywhere and twitter
is not uh twitter's a business
how to make money they're not out there
to decide who's telling the truth or
lying
leslie
the white house has this nina jankowicz
or whatever her name is who's the
disinformations are and they are
actually tweeting out a lie and they're
not even and they're still on twitter
why isn't why can they lie on something
as important as when the vaccine was
available can't you admit that's a lie
is it a lie yes or no it's not an
accurate statement
it's not an accurate state but can i say
something about elon musk because of
course uh no surprise i'm going to be
saying something different than the rest
of you but somebody agrees with me and i
actually said it first that elon musk
wasn't going to buy this for this price
tag and the person who said that is
donald trump
uh mr trump after i leslie marshall said
that so i told you so he's not gonna buy
it i disagree with you i think this is
um somebody who likes attention i think
it's a circus i think he's having fun it
was an outrageous amount of money
and i just don't think the deal is ever
going to happen
i think he owes a billion penalty yeah
if the deal doesn't go through he
sanctioned the billion dollars it's the
worst kind of prenup out there yeah
elon musk is hit with an sec
investigation over tardy twitter stake
disclosure i mean it took him 10 days to
say was he was buying it or whatever the
claim is but don't you think a guy like
elon musk is a target for everyone on
the left for by barack obama to come out
and say i'm in favor of content
moderation and this is this information
board i mean they're gunning for this
guy big time
you know i'm on the left and i don't
care whether donald trump's on twitter
or not i don't put as much importance in
twitter as perhaps some of my fellow
democrats do and what elon musk does or
doesn't do uh really i'm sorry it
doesn't really affect my life i know but
then that's that it affects the world
he's just some rich guy tyrone who likes
it 30 seconds it affects the left they
hate this one
they've been able to say whatever they
want and then anyone who disagrees with
them they've been able to punish or
banish so yeah and again even if he
doesn't buy it he's exposing and the
american people are going to see how
little actual real effect twitter has
we've been he's ripping off the curtain
for the wizard of oz he's not waiting
he's ripping the curtain off and while
they're doing the bangs and whistles
they're finding out that it was mostly
just propaganda so that's that's even if
he doesn't buy it it's a win for
americans okay hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else